edward is at the center of a really
interesting story he's a truck driver
for a furniture company most people had
not heard of him outside of his
immediate friends and family then just
the other day came out of nowhere to be
one of the most powerful politicians in
the state of new jersey a machine
politics state that be the president of
the new jersey state senate a man called
steve sweeney
edward durr spent 153 dollars on his
primary campaign now he's going to
represent new jersey's third legislative
district library joins us tonight mr
durr senator
we're honored to have you on tonight um
so i i gotta ask you how
much were you motivated to run for
office by concerns like inflation and
gas prices was that meaningful to you
oh well everything's meaningful to me
but it just became
a as i keep telling people a perfect
storm you not only had the high cost of
living in the state the
worst tax rate the worst business tax
rate you you had people being told they
couldn't live they couldn't go to stores
they couldn't go to church you had
nursing home deaths it just became a
combination of everything and i got fed
up with it and i said i'm not leaving
the state i'm going to fix the state
well that seems like that's what i chose
to do i mean that's a triumph of
democracy right you know it's a citizen
who decides he wants a hand in running
his government but you weren't
congratulated by a lot of media outlets
they immediately attacked you for saying
naughty things on twitter or whatever
were you surprised that you weren't the
subject of a feature film after this
triumph
[Laughter]
uh no no i i i i this is all a surprise
i knew it was a major thing to beat the
senate president he had been in there a
long time but everybody else has kind of
made it a big deal you know i had a lot
of great people around me i had my
county chair jackie vigilante and my
political director steve kush leading
the path and to be i have to get it out
there tucker there was a lot of people
who won not just myself you had my two
running mates bethany mccarthy patrick
and beth sawyer
and then you had nick desilvio and chris
conawell who won county commissioner and
he had john simmons who won the first
african-american sheriff in our county
and these people all worked hard we all
knocked doors
what have you talked to sweeney since
you dethroned him i mean how baffled is
he
yes yes we we had a uh phone
conversation yesterday after he uh given
his uh press
conference to the media and he
congratulated me and just wish me luck
to
do well for south jersey
so he was a gentleman about it
yeah yeah yeah he was a gentleman
good for him and and we we
you know and like i told him i said
you know if he ever needed anything just
give me a call you know because
i'm i'm
his representative now
that's so great
mr nerd congratulations it's great to
talk to you thank you well i just want
to let everybody know if they ever want
to look me up just go to
edthetrucker.com
they can find out more about me and help
me out